so this week we talked about the satanic
altar that had been set up inside the
Iowa capitol building and it was put
there by the satanic temple as a
response to the manger scene that is
also inside the Capitol Building uh the
temple claims that it has the religious
liberty to set up satanic altars in
government buildings if it wants to and
the Iowa state government didn't even
attempt to fight them on it there was no
uh the only thing the Iowa state
government fought them on was that you
can't have an actual severed goat goat's
head but which is what they originally
wanted uh but other than that go ahead
Satanist set up your altar in the state
house and uh so they relented right away
and they let this depraved mockery occur
well yesterday a man named Michael
Cassidy uh decided Iowa residents uh a
veteran decided to do something about it
and and here's what he did this is the
post-millennial reporting a satanic
altar erected in the Iowa capital
building has been torn down and beheaded
by a Christian and former military
officer according to the Sentinel
Michael Cassidy pushed over and
decapitated the statue which was placed
in the building by um members of the
satanic temple of Iowa after receiving
permission and discarded the head of the
statue into the trash Cassie told the
outlet that he destroyed the altar on uh
Thursday to awaken Christians to the
anti-christian acts promoted by our
government Cassie said quote the world
may tell Christians to submissively
accept the legitimization of Satan but
none of the founders would have
considered government sanction of
satanic altars inside capital buildings
as protected by the First Amendment
anti-christian values have steadily been
mainstreamed more and more in recent
decades and Christians have largely
acted like proverbial frogs in the
boiling pots of
water uh Cy turned himself into officers
who were present in the building who
confirmed the satanic temple of Iowa
seeks to press charges cassidie was
charged with fourth-degree criminal
mischief Cassie said quote I saw this
Blasphemous statue and was outraged my
conscience is held captive to the word
of God not to bureaucratic decree and so
I
acted just uh I mean awesome great
response um and uh great to see it and
by the way what he said is everything he
said is obviously completely correct
including the point about our founding
fathers would not have considered this
protected by the first am and everybody
knows that don't even try like do you
really think the founding fathers would
have accepted satanic
altars inside
you know uh the the State House of any
state which founding father do you think
would have endorsed
that of course they wouldn't we all know
that now the update here is that there
was a legal defense fund set up for
Cassidy by The Sentinel which is the
outlet that initially reported on this
and uh I was happy to chip into his
legal defense tpsa pledged $110,000 I
think um they're only looking to raise
20,000 and they raised it in like three
hours and then they the campaign so I'd
say this is a win so far overall
somebody took down the display they took
matters into their own hands they took
the initiative a bunch of people rallied
to support that
person and uh and it's a win I mean it's
a big
win um now there have been
some uh on the right well of course you
know on the left in fact I just saw
someone tweeted out saying this was a
bigoted this was a bigoted
act okay bigoted against who the devil
like this is this is devil phobia Satan
phobia is that is that sure yeah you're
right um so you had that on the left as
expect but even some on the
right as you would also expect have uh
expressed concerns they're
concerned I don't know I'm concerned but
this concerns me it's concerning I'm a
little
concerned and so they've accused us
those who support Michael Cassie they
accused us of of supporting and cheering
on what legally qualifies as
vandalism that's what they've accused us
of and and yes that's exactly right that
is what we're cheering on they also say
that the satanic temple has the the
First Amendment right to set up its
satanic altar inside a government
building we may not like it but you know
if they want to set up a satanic altar
in every state house in the country
there's nothing we can do about it we
can't do anything have to sit back every
state house could be turned into a
satanic into a into a platform for
worshiping the devil and there's nothing
we could do we just can't do and for the
sake of Freedom this is freedom this is
what freedom
is the holidays are rapidly approaching
but we can find peace and calm in the
craziness of the season with hallow the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
world immerse yourself in Christmas and
Advent prayers meditations and peaceful
Christmas music hallow also offers an
extensive library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audio guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey Hall provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year podcast in
which he offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the Hallow app also connects you to uh
uh like-minded individuals sharing
experiences insights and encouragement
along the path to spiritual growth this
Christmas join Hallow's Christmas prayer
challenge Advent with CS Lewis for the
25 days leading up to Christmas you can
join you can focus on the real reason
for the season with prayer meditation
and Christmas music on hallow download
the app for free at hall.com Walsh for
three months free that's hall.com
Walsh they say that if if we think that
it's okay to have a manger
scene then we also have to think it's
okay to have a satanic altar that's the
claim right that's the equivalent so if
we're opposed to BLM riers torching a
CVS we have to also be opposed to a guy
decapitating a satanic Altar and if we
support a manger scene then we also have
to support a satanic altar we have to
treat everything
equally these conservatives claim
because everything is the same we're not
allowed to notice any difference between
things they're all the same and that's
what it means to be free that's what
freedom is
um but no that's not
correct everything is not the
same you know that everything is not the
same everyone knows it we all know
that okay you know these things are not
the same we don't have to pretend to
believe
otherwise so here's my basic position on
this and and I do think as i' as I've
argued that there is a legal argument
here here that the satanic altar is not
valid religious expression under the
First Amendment um as I've been saying
all along you know according to the The
Satanist themselves the whole Satanism
thing is essentially a parody a mockery
they don't even pretend to have a
theological belief in the reality of
Satan so I don't think that even by pure
legal standards this qualifies this
first
amendment expression but let's forget
that for a second because that's not my
fundamental
point my fundamental point is
this and this this is going to blow your
mind
um good things are
good bad things are
bad that's it that's what I believe so I
support good things and I don't support
bad
things I think that good things should
happen and I think that bad things
shouldn't happen and so when a good
thing happens I say that's good and when
a bad thing happens I said that's bad so
that's how I approach life and know it's
it's revolutionary I mean this is a
maybe to you if you're a normal per if
you're a sane person this is not
revolutionary but but to a lot of
conservatives this is re this is a
revolutionary concept the idea that well
oh so you can notice when something is
good and treat it as good and when
something is bad you can treat it as bad
I really I said that's no this is that's
that's not what the founders would have
wanted that's not what Thomas Jefferson
would have
wanted honestly I don't care if that's
what he would wanted you know if that's
what he wanted or didn't want I don't
care anyway but uh but you're incorrect
on what the founders would have
wanted so the idea that I'm Bound by the
principle of Liberty and human rights to
draw no distinction between good and bad
is
insane um and and that is an idea that
the guys who came up with the doctrine
of human rights which lies to the
foundation of our country did not
believe so they themselves did not share
this modern notion that in order to
respect everyone's rights we have to
pretend that everything is the same and
be just as welcoming of bad things as we
are of good that is again insane it's
ridiculous I want a good society that is
ordered towards the good and where
goodness is encouraged and welcomed and
I want a society where therefore Badness
is discouraged and unwelcomed this is
basic
stuff so uh putting this in
practice if a guy spray paints you know
uh graffiti on a cop
car um you know he sprays aab on a cop
car or whatever during a BLM
right um and then you know you've got
that kind of anals and then over here
you've got a guy uh dismantling a
satanic
altar are those the same well no because
the guy with the spray paint is doing
something that's obviously
bad and the guy who's getting rid of the
satanic altar is doing something that is
good and so I see them as different for
that reason
alone is a Manger the same thing as a
satanic altar are we bound to
that well you support the manger you're
stuck with the satanic altar it's just
the way it is you can't you're impotent
you are impotent in the face of the SAT
no because the manger is
good and the satanic altar is bad
I can make that distinction so can you
so can
everybody and then you're left well
who's to say what's good who's to say
what's
bad if you find yourself saying that
about Satan well who's to say that Satan
is bad it's like literally the
definition of bad
so
um no who who's to say what's good and
bad uh I don't know all of us like we
all know this is natural law you know
these are these are these are basic
moral insights that everyone has access
to how do we know that a satanic altar
in the state capital is bad uh or you
know who's to say that we we all know
that every single one of us knows
it the only difference is that some
people pretend they don't know
it hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there